[Music]
we'll be back home for dad's famous pork
and beans in no time he's everything
yeah daddy trust was right she does
steal kids and turn them into robots
honey Danny Petrosky is a liar and a
[ __ ] I'm sorry but it's true I know
she's got the baby what to what the
baby's nappy me you're acting crazy
you've got to stop that evil robot lady
it's what Decker moon boots would do
don't you dare go in that house sorry
mom also if you want to fall and make
sure everyone is okay and alive that
would be nice
that's Italian silk you savage you made
an exit tunnel
Gwendoline you all saved everybody
[Music]
there's a big fluffy kitty for mama for
you to come upstairs with me now
[Music]
Jimbo these crazy killer kitties are
gonna find us any second we have to get
out of here
now but she just saved our lives she
says yours two times was all due respect
embarrassing but he does have a point
Oh sort of I could have gotten away on
my own probably so it's only right that
we send her a proper thank-you card Oh
fine yes we'll go save her danger
today's been a real roller coaster how
we gonna get past those pants I have an
inside the box idea
[Music]
[Music]
No
[Music]
[Music]
do not judge me Wendy Janice aah I can
explain this oh those sweaters you gave
me their Thanksgiving around food
you said they were cashmere I clearly
said cat smear you heard what you wanted
you